bein a to one of the eight games to only
have achieved the 10 of 10 on GameSpot
calm oh yeah you and you wrote some
reviews for those games in fact you're
the only two people left in the building
who ever in any tens of those eight yeah
you were number one with ocarina right I
was
yeah ocarina time ended up being the
first ten at that time we were a video
game spot so we were we were the
separate crew that hid in the back and
used the word hella a lot and then
GameSpot was PC focused and and very
much like these animals doing here
so when I came back after a so they sent
ocarina on a Friday and the review could
run Monday so I got the cartridge went
home did you sleep no a little bit
that is there's actually I think that
that experience was documented on the
site you know next forum somewhere
weirdly enough and wanted to give it a
10 and basically that led to a
conversation that's probably out an hour
long with Vince Brody who was one of the
founders of GameSpot and he was the one
who was in charge of all editorial the
three founders of GameSpot were kind of
like they were focused like Vince was
editorial yeah he was kind of the tech
and then John Epstein was business and
so was it just you and him having each
other yeah he called me into his office
and basically just tried to poke holes
in it over and over again in a way that
at the time I thought was actually
really frustrating because we you know
he was saying like this game is not
voice acting how can you say the sounds
of 10 this is when we were scoring on
component scores so as well as this
sounds graphics gameplay sound value and
reviewers tilt woo which makes reviewers
till it actually made perfect sense it's
not worth it's not gonna do that my
birthday and so he just sat there kind
of poked holes like wouldn't be better
for that voice acting wouldn't be better
if had this ands like well you know the
standards of the consoles are the stuff
like if these are the policies that we
review by absolutely not this is a sound
10 all the way and he kind of grilled me
on it for a while and then at the end of
it went alright that's what you want to
do which was actually the worst thing he
could have said like [ __ ] dammit but
yeah we ended up going through and give
10 the thing that always happens I was
really excited when I saw the tank
firsthand since I've been working at
GameSpot and I always remember like
there was just always backlash there's
always a part of the community who just
fundamentally thinks this one was better
in the series or yeah yeah you run into
stuff like that but I think you know the
thing we ran into in the early days was
that the word under 10 said perfect
right and so it was it was it wasn't
necessarily about other games it was
just about no games perfect any game
could be better like even today people
refer to it as the perfect score which
is kind of yeah and I think since then
like we've you know like when we
redesigned the scoring system on
GameSpot to remove the component scores
and all other stuff at that time we took
perfect off of it and made its a prime
instead which you know was it was the
best word we could come up with that
time I guess but uh you know the the
idea you know and with justify it in a
way and saying like you know it ended up
saying like it's as perfect as a game
can be by today's standards and you know
it's like it was like a back explanation
for it that worked well at the time but
eventually yeah like moving it to prime
and saying like you know yeah you're
right no game can ever be perfect but
like who stopped this yeah this is a
dumb argument was the right move I think
and next came up with Soul Calibur yeah
who did that wonder with it I want to
say that was a James milky review okay
was that in-house or freeline was it
house yeah he was in-house at that point
he came out I think he was doing user
reviews for us go out we brought him in
and so he was with the site for a while
and I want to say he reviewed that and
gave that a 10 you gave it that done oh
I never sent like top five games of all
time for me did you start user reviews
well Kevin yeah that's actually uh kind
of how I got into GameSpot was I did use
reviews and I was a moderator on the
site for years we had a pretty hot
pipeline for a while of hiring people
out of the community Carolyn as well the
community
I kind of was involved with the
community but yeah yeah Kay minded a
different angle at Chrono Cross yeah
Chrono Cross this is probably the one
that comes up a lot I mean no because
who talked about Chrono Cross in this
day and age that one was that one was
interesting because it was freelanced
out so it was someone who's not on staff
and well you know we were paying someone
paying some mercenary
there to review the game for us and it
came back at 10:00 and it was the sort
of thing where it's like okay now we're
kind of in a bind because no one on
staff has played this game no one can
vouch for it one way or the other it's
just kind of it I'm with Bayonetta
actually but we'll get into that yeah so
you end up in this situation where
you're like you know I'm I'm gonna say
you know I tried to kind of I remember
trying to poke kind of holes in it the
in his braudy way to some extent but it
got to a point where it's like okay we
kind of need someone else to to vouch
for its we went to another freelancer
that was on our staff that had also
played it and said like what you think
you think this games a 10 and the
response was oh yes absolutely
mmm so like okay well we're gonna go
through and give it a 10 so how I
remember going down is the review got
published it was live and then I
responded said all right it's it's up
now and you know it's the that's a
perfect game and then the response from
the guy that we had check it said oh I
never said it was perfect
oh no got a instant horse I thought wow
how did you feel then going up with Tony
Hawk pro skater 3 that was number four
games incredible that a game is still a
me Tony Hawk - you got a nine point nine
were you gonna go from there
not that it was about yeah that but you
know the if you look at Tony Hawk 3 on
the PlayStation 2
they pet that game hat online in it
before they had issued the official
network adapter Wow
so you know you could plug in like a
weird USB Ethernet adapter and play
online like you know like the the
lengths they went to in that game and
they completed the scoring system by
adding reverting all other stuff like
alchemy Tony Hawk 3 was where they
finally linked it all together it looked
amazing at the time that Tokyo level had
the round bowls and the cool sound
effects and stuff great and track again
yeah yeah a terrific soundtrack like I
know a lot of people go like oh twos
better they're wrong I thought I would I
thought the consensus was there free was
Tony Hawk yeah I do it was great yeah I
feel like for gets into an area where
it's like now it's kind of like larger
areas and stuff like they started
getting away from and they have to like
obviously they can't just put up the
same game again it's this the Activision
of today not the item isn't it man um
and so it's just pop bam margera and
call of duty and yeah
Bam Margera is playing a concert in my
hometown at the end of this month ok I
don't go
I don't know answer I don't know what
that means his name is just on the
marquee I've gotta see here's a shitty
band oh yeah yeah oh it's really awful I
just Bam Margera shows up with an
accordion and stuff you know just like a
few bear worship God oh right and then I
think it's like electronic music and
sings oh that makes sense
this was like easy in a hymn cover band
that would make too much sense his
girlfriend as I understand it is from my
hometown so no case he is there a fair
amount anyway yeah Tony och3 is
incredible and anyone that disagrees is
actually completely wrong well if you
think Tony Hawk 2 was a better game
you're [ __ ] wrong that was 2001 and
then it was 7 years until the next one
why which and this one is quite
contentious as well it was grand theft
auto 4 2004 was the calvert and we gave
a review of that I completely agree I
absolutely adore GTA 4 but I know that
I'm probably in the minority no GTA
fours an amazing game yeah I think I
agree with every one of these except for
Chrono Cross over oh really after some
of the best games of all time or
anything that when Ford came out it was
like legitimately incredible like I
remember for yeah yeah course that was
interesting I mean cuz I because then I
was here by this point it's actually
interesting because we'd had we'd had
ten submitted before but then they never
Jason Ocampo would give half life to
attend oh yeah we said no and he want to
get crisis of ten if I was crisis
correctly the first crisis I think he
wanted to give it an eye like Christ oh
I'm not sure but but half-life 2 is a
good shout but I got damn it but GTA
Thor I think we were we were actually
going back and forth because at that
point we had the point five increments
and everything yes and then so it was
like okay so was it a nine fibres of ten
nine five ten nine five ten we ended up
landing on the ten actually it was 95 on
ps3 and it was ten on 360 I think was it
yeah one of them wasn't ten well I know
that we gave the PC version a nine okay
when that came out but we did give GTA
it was the first ten with in years and
years and then the same year we gave yes
my ten another four maybe the most
content it might be actually the most
contentious ten I'd love to hear a Riker
to think about this which oh really
Oh
Metal Gear Solid 4 okay um so a game
that I stand for three right I think
there's an argument for any one of the
four yeah officially ourselves you can
argue for any one of those four being
the but I [ __ ] love Metal Gear Solid
four and Windows yeah when we did our
retrospective a couple years ago and I
got the chance I you know just pulled
that out and started playing it's like
oh god this is so right on the money for
that time I was so it's still I really
stand by I mean there are a few reviews
we always have those couple reviews it
was like yeah maybe in retrospect I was
a little a little excitable over that
one but man I will stand by that ten
just as much as I stand by that nine for
the original assassins were you like
nervous at all being like from the
community and knowing the importance and
like you know were you nervous at all
that like you weren't sure if this was
that type of game like what's the what's
the mindset there and then honestly that
when so one of the things of the last
big things I did at GameSpot was kind of
write that review system right to go
from the components core system down to
the half points and stuff and the I
originally actually wanted to go five
stars with that stuff and again you know
we've kind of decided on a middle ground
with that stuff and by design that
should make tens easier to give yeah we
took perfect off of it like it wasn't
designed to make scores higher it was
designed to be like you know let's just
put the power back in the editors hands
get away from this mathematical formula
that makes less and less sense as we add
more reviews to the site so that was
when all the reviewers Hilton games yeah
like that stuff kind of went away and
was replaced by that emblem system that
I thought was cool I mean I miss emblems
a lot yeah me too it was it was the the
case where the original idea behind
emblems was we were supposed to be able
to add them on a really regular basis as
games changed and then getting the
design resources to do that
proved to be a completely different
stories I remember hearing from Ryan Mac
that sometimes when you submitted - the
algorithm wasn't known so when you hit
like publish with all those that you
didn't actually know what the final
score was going to be down to the
decimal we had there was an engineer
named Clovis Addison who
and he was he made a spreadsheet for me
that had the math in it okay so it was
like game play times 0.3 and you know it
was just like whatever it was a weighted
formula yeah so game play mattered the
most game playing reviewers till were
equal value and graphics I want to say
we're equal and then sound was the
lowest that's great it's about yearly
made the yeah so it ended up being that
every every time you moved reviewers
tilt up a point
it added point three to overall score
and so the one thing that did happen is
that the rounding that the site used was
different than the rounding the
spreadsheet used right so you would
enter something that would come up eight
seven and put it up in to be an eight
six knee but no whatever and then the
video reviews had to be like redone I
heard because okay they've been put out
by that's by that by the time we were
doing video reviews like the the ability
to preview stuff on the site was a
little bigger a little bit better but
the thing that would happen is like
oftentimes as part of the peer review
process of everyone reading the review
and commenting on it you would see a
score change a little bit here and there
based on those conversations people be
like you say the values an eight but
when I read this it sounds like a four
or a seven or something you know so like
all those tweaks would have and those
conversations still happen like one of
the things that they made people don't
are aware of and I didn't I kind of
didn't appreciate until I joined three
years ago was the amount of peer review
that happened so every review like
basically gets sent around every single
editor on staff and is scrutineers
almost yeah I mean traditionally I mean
when I started it goes copy edit first
is how it was done before we don't have
a copy editor right now but we go to
copy edit first and then it was it goes
back you know the editor puts in all the
changes puts into the system and we have
a department that actually then entered
those into the CMS that was a really
that was great laborious way of doing it
yeah but now I mean we just you know but
but then it goes around the entire
editorial team and everybody gets to
chime in and let me tell you there if
people think that we just lazily throw
stuff up on the site bayonetta went
through three rounds of QA oh yeah I
mean there are reviews that we've
delayed for almost a week
yeah I mean there have been taught a
couple reviews I've killed arm in the
past just because they did did it just
didn't get to where it needed to
I savour just know just that it wasn't
written well or didn't argue the score
or in that multiple rewrites didn't
really get there and you know there have
been a few times where we've reassigned
based on stuff like that but crazy at
number seven was as Super Mario Galaxy 2
oh yeah I which was Tom McShea right yes
yeah and that was a that was a fun
conversation I mean typically what these
meant when you know when when I was you
know after a you know when when Justin
was was kind of in charge of the stuff
it was all of us gathering into Justin's
office and like for an hour two hours
whatever and throwing around every
single pro and con making the reviewer
really argue the point you know being
devil's advocate whenever it made sense
and I'm very good at being a devil's
advocate so but yeah smg2 Doc's suits
pretty great video again what you say oh
really
Tom originally submitted that ya pro
over ten yeah he read everything this is
a ten yeah this games I mean actually I
would say it's pretty close to if
something can be called perfect yeah
like I'd say that's that's a game that
really kind of deserves to be thrown
into that category hero complaints about
this game at all yeah yeah and I was
number seven the number H we had to wait
a couple of years but a Bayonetta 2 and
so yeah we're kind of in a situation
there where we have a it went from you
know I remember growing up reading like
old Amiga magazines actually PC gamer
had until until a couple years ago had
the 100% like scale where it was
everything from 0 to 100 and GameSpot
was on the sort of 20 points for know it
was like individual increments over well
it was a lot of points and when we
changed it was technically 19 points
because the lowest score was 1.0 oh you
couldn't get it you can get a 0 or 0.5
or whatever what's why big rigs over
there is 1.0 and they managed to get it
in a box and put it out that's close
enough
yeah so so we changed it to that that
scale and then now what I don't actually
know what you guys yeah so it's 10 point
now this is essential now yeah Takia
essential as the determent obviously you
kind of it's pretty prime when you form
Giant Bomb you kind of got your own way
to the 5 sorry
did the thing I wanted to do and just
made a five-star scale at that point not
like I actually made the argument that
GameSpot should have moved to that when
it redesigned but it didn't happen we
wouldn't have the problems with
Metacritic you guys have though it's not
like we don't know we actually we
translate to Metacritic better than any
other outlet out there into you think so
with the five point our four and our
five stars get colored green our three
star gets colored yellow r1 and r2 get
colored red and today I don't care what
other outlets give games and how we
match up with on that scale but our four
our five star reviews are favorable our
three stars I like - hmm and then our
one or two are like mm-hm
what would you think if say like some of
the bigger sites did convert to fives
are like with all of the weirds like
messed up responsibilities stuff that's
happening with like publishers paying
developers based on their Metacritic
scores and stuff like that like as
reviewers our duty is to the people that
are interested in information about
which games they want to buy the
whatever the industry does behind that
is something that a reviewer especially
cannot concern themselves with so you
know like I think those deals are not
necessarily great for developers and
they should think twice about signing
them yeah but you know that's that's
obviously you know they at some point
wants to do the deal and if that's
that's what I have to do this what they
have to do but yeah I mean ultimately
you know we we have to serve the
audience of people that trust us to be
open and honest about the quality of
these games so like you know Metacritic
is the last thing I think about when
when doing this stuff after the fact
I'll go look and go oh we are the lowest
in Metacritic yeah why does everyone
like this game so much the hell's wrong
I just look at like these people are
idiots and then we've all the driveclub
didn't get a 5 to 5 no it's not no it
did not there was a very old school it
was very classic in a weird way of like
having people come at me over driveclub
it's been a long time yes anyone has and
um it was kind of fun in a weird way it
was like oh how quaint you people still
do this weird daily care days way back
then yeah well that stuff was whatever
that that was I mean that was like the
stuff of like giving Zelda and 8.8 and
then Mario Sunshine I gave an 8 yeah
which stirred up a similar thing was
just like it was like me and Alex just
like
getting emails and just laughing like
what's people yeah okay man sure
whatever okay one of my favorite
phenomenon that used to happen after
after giant bomb was created is is I'd
get a lot of messages saying wealthy old
GameSpot guys were still here they'd
never give Crysis Crysis 2 is a test
five stars it's like the old as like
have you seen the giant Pommery let me
throw you over there on your way so it
that's always the the strangest one
where it's just like somehow the I mean
it's good you kind of go along and
people kind of put you up a little
little pedestal after one yes like oh
the the good old days what happened with
destiny as well I guess a couple of
weeks ago similar kind of yeah I mean we
ended up actually like having the the
exact same score and I see I actually
heard yeah I mean we gave it a 3 out of
5 right so you guys give a look at 6 oh
right yep so mathematically is the
cinematic exactly the same thing the
math works out yeah but yeah I actually
didn't hear from anyone about destiny
yeah when when that review went up it
was very much like a yeah I guess I
can't really argue with that I'm playing
it really like it but yeah those are all
valid I mean the drought a lot of the
driveclub reaction was that way too
it was just Erte who is complaining
about destiny well whatever they ruined
assault rifles for him so I telling him
today to never play that game ever again
oh gosh just like bad and dota right
review for that coming up soon as well
dota yeah yeah for video game store and
thanks very much because I wonder when
the next one will be number 9 any any
takers who knows that I never saw my
passable Tony Hawk reboot ok yeah Tony
Hawk ride too
yeah yeah um advanced warfare ah maybe I
mean anything anything awesome game can
be awesome any game could be [ __ ] let's
have the one conversation we don't have
just one one anymore we have three ones
well you know you're you're also not big
we're interesting yeah you're not you're
not group digging out games from Walmart
store shelves and stuff anymore either
yeah they just show up on Steam now all
sorts of [ __ ] to show where we need it
the flood of stuff on Steam is insane
yeah
craziness all right gentlemen take firm
what's going on appreciate that's the
show for this week
we done and Mary do you have a Lea
what's on next week's show
No all right students love it based on 2
p.m. Pacific and thanks very much
hanging out and we'll see you guys next
week
adios one more
you